the Nasdaq took 31 months who's counting
to plunge seventy-eight percent after
the internet bubble burst in two
thousand climbing out of that hole took
13 years of your life and yesterday the
index closed at a fresh all-time higher
senior markets correspondent Julie Hyman
makes it feel old if you remember all
you know if you were there throughout
Julie okay so yeah I tell us give us
some context on this well it did take a
long time for the Nasdaq to climb out of
that hole longer than it took of course
for the sp500 and the Dow as well so the
Nasdaq was up 351 percent over that
period from the lows that we saw in
March of 2002 until just yesterday when
it hit that record and compare that with
advances of less than half for the Dow
and the S&P 500 so because we saw the
Nasdaq fall more from the heights of the
tech bubble we saw it have to climb more
to sort of claw out of that hole which a
dunk for itself and we've heard a lot of
people talk about you know that this
peak this Nasdaq does look very
different than it did at that point in
time Betty Wright and Julie so so give
me a sense of like the biggest change in
the landscape from today and back in two
thousand so one good way to measure it
is to look at the top market caps during
the bubble compared with now and you get
a sense of the changing landscape so
then the top market cap in the Nasdaq
was microsoft now it's Apple a company
that really wasn't even on the map at
that point in time you go from Cisco to
Google again here you get a change
really a sense of the changing of the
guard in technology Oracle to Facebook a
company that didn't even exist at that
point in time and then second Sun
Microsystems jeans Sun Microsystems
amazon so really you see there that sort
of encapsulates the change that has
occurred within technology